Larry why do you feel that beetlejuice
old why did that screenplay sell in your
opinion yeah you know this is gonna
sound so pretentious maybe but when when
I decided I was going to be a writer
again and decided I was going to do
Michael in my mind I said to myself I'm
so awful
thank you but I'm going to write a
classic well I'm not just going to write
another movie we are going to create a
classic and who knows what that means
and again it sounds obnoxious maybe but
we knew probably I don't know 20-some
pages in that just something was
happening and we weren't thinking about
demographics we weren't thinking about
who the audience was going to be we
weren't thinking about any any
quote-unquote commercial aspects of it
we were thinking what's good what's
funny what's making its laugh what's
moving the story forward what are the
Zanies craziest ideas we can have and it
just and it happens with with with
scripts and it happens in your writing
there's just times that you feel that
you're in a zone and you're in a place
that you're so connecting with yourself
and you're so connecting with what your
vision is that if you can get on a page
other people are going to see it and
feel it to do and that movie was was
that and we didn't know what was going
to happen with it when the movie was
finished there were people Warner
Brothers in the marketing department who
absolutely hated it they wanted to
change the title the house ghost and
dump it and back in the days when you'd
put it in a thousand theaters or
something and let it run a week and then
hopefully it would go away
that wasn't everyone
and we had David Geffen on our side so
we were protected but it was hardly
loved but I knew who we were writing it
for and and a my mind and it's very 80s
reference there was a band there so bad
The Cure the great cure band I loved and
I had gone to see them at the Rose Bowl
huge concert maybe 50,000 people and it
felt to me like it was 50,000 teenage
girls in black yeah you know right you
know Syria and and that was and and that
when an erotic character Lydia came out
of that and I always that I thought
that's who the audience for this movie
is and as we were writing it and and I
that for me and it may have been
different from my goal but that was
always who I thought this movie was
being written for and and it's really a
family story and it's about a girl who
needs a mom and a dad and and and and
because her real mom and dad just don't
understand her don't spend enough time
with her so she ends up with two ghosts
that's the heart of that movie and
that's what I was writing towards and
the must and and that so so finally it's
it's released and I go to see it a
nearby where we're sitting now at
Universal on a Friday night it's the
first Friday night and I watch it with
an audience a real audience for the
first time Christopher Vincent test
audiences and all of that and people are
coming out of it either loving it or
hating it which I thought great that's
exactly what we wanted and that was that
was Friday night then Saturday night I
went back and I saw a bunch of teenage
girls who had gone into their closet
having seen it on Friday night
and came back dressed like window writer
Lydia deeds and I thought okay it's a
hit we have connected with the audience
to the point that are already dressing
up as Lydia and then there was a
marketing meeting at Warner Brothers
that may have been on the monday and it
had surpassed everyone's expectations in
terms of the grosses and the the
audience feedback and it was obvious
that that that it would that it was
going to take off and be something
special and again in in this no-name
zone there was a about mr. day there was
a marketing person who I always remember
as a guy who would wear a scarf no
matter what the temperature was okay and
and and it was a member Tim Burton being
there and David Geffen being there and
the Michaels and myself and this
marketing person all he could say all he
could the best he could do was well at
least we got the little girls in black
to come see it and we walked out of the
meeting and Tim said well who the eff
did we think he made it for yeah do you
think we made it for and and and it was
just it and and and one thing when
things are going well in my writing and
I think it's true for all writers that
if you're like intensely self-conscious
about who is your audience who who is it
you know is this for the 12 to 16 you're
doing that you're not writing well and
you get in a zone and your story starts
telling you you're not telling the story
it's emerging from someplace within you
and that's what Beetlejuice was and I
just always had that and I used to say
to Michael sometimes because I could
feel it going well and I'd say Michael
you know we're gonna have a toy line you
can go shut up shut up
is finish the script yeah but I I mean
it's a very hard thing to explain what
that what that what that it's it's an
epiphany after an epiphany and that you
feel like you're just onto something
bigger than you you know well going back
to the other no-name person yeah then
did they ever reach out to you here they
kind of put you in a spot where you're
almost on alleged metaphorically and
then you're just elated with validation
that this worked even though maybe you
didn't totally expect it what did that
person ever reach out to no okay no
because II it because that would have
required a certain amount of humility
and a certain willingness to to say you
know what I on this one and not everyone
has that ability
you